so who just resigned who just resigned
cnn jeff zucker just resigned which let
me for say cnn worldwide presented
president jeff zucker the influential
news executive who reshaped the iconic
network this
cnn wrote this article about so i'm
reading this yeah so the way they wrote
it
who reshaped the iconic network abruptly
announced wednesday morning that he has
resigned from his position in fact
immediately as part of the investigation
to chris comos tenure cnn i was asked
about a consensual relationship my
closest colleague someone had worked
with for more than 20 years i
acknowledged the relationship evolved in
recent years i was required to disclose
it when it began but i didn't i was
wrong as a result i'm resigning today
that's not why yeah zucker did not name
his colleague in the memo but the
relationship is with allison golast the
chief marketing officer for cnn she is
still staying with sienna so watch this
okay
let's throw so you know how you go to a
restaurant you first order your drink
i'd like to have a you know arnold
palmer they bring the orange sorry we're
out of lemonade
would you like some salad i'll take i'll
take some brother cheese salad with some
balsamic glaze on the side fantastic
thank you would you like to go do some
appetizers yes i'll have some uh
fried zucchini flowers and some uh you
know uh steak uh tartar some oysters
there's some oysters and a faux gras and
some bone marrow no problem no boneless
buffalo strips that's coming back now
you know where my eats and where are
patties
can we get some mesquite chicken all
right someone go that router yes without
any would you like some dessert yes i'll
take some whatever dessert sundae or you
know sorbet or whatever they bring
dessert here you know what the dessert
would be here
if elon went and bought cnn
i'm gonna buy cnn that would be amazing
if something like that were to happen if
you were to say i'm gonna cut a check
and buy cnn
people with would lose it okay and by
the way if they bought cnn overnight you
would see all the airports they would no
longer show cnn it would be msnbc yeah
for sure why do you think they are
they're not going to let elon have
control to show
that would scare the crap out of them
that scared the crap out of my feet
that's something like do the airports
have some sort of arrangement with cnn
is that is that their
the
airport show cnn that's that's right i
mean is that is that just the airports
majority of airports show cnn you go to
texas they'll have cnn and fox
what's the story behind that in florida
they show nickelodeon that's what they
show
but in new york and i don't even tell
you what new york shows you new rook
shows a whole different uh perspective
but yeah it's mainly
a lot of
cnn what are your thoughts on what
happened here with uh zunker what was
the real story here oh i think cuomo got
him fired
specifically cuomo i absolutely love
cuomo got him fired why why because
zucker threw coma under the bus
you don't remember when it first came
out and it's like zucker yeah we have to
let cuomo go and then
cuomo's like wait a minute no no you
ain't gonna make me look like an idiot
my father's mario cuomo we don't let the
bully bully us
no here's what we're going to be doing
this is exactly what you did as well and
then zucker got fired so zucker got
fired
by the person he fired chris cuomo can i
read a quote yeah as part of the
investigation into chris cuomo's tenure
here at cnn i was asked about a
consensual relationship with my closest
colleague someone i've worked with for
more than 20 years zucker
told employees in a memo i acknowledge
the relationship evolved in recent years
i was required to disclose it when it
began but i didn't
i was wrong as a result i'm resigning
today soccer did not name his colleague
in the memo but relationship with alison
golist the chief marketing officer for
cnn
is remaining at cnn
so what's your what's just apparently
inappropriate work relationships or not
even inappropriate not disclosing it i
mean there's no way that that took place
for 20 years and everybody didn't know
about it everybody had to know that he
was banging alice yeah to me there's
there's just got to be more to it i mean
how about the fact that they've lost 90
percent of their viewers how does that
not not play some role in this has to be
well you know look
but by the way just think about it think
about it what network did trump call
fake news
santa so just did you see trump's
comment about cnn did you see trump's
comment about zucker did you read it or
no yeah why don't you pull out what
trump said about the
zucker getting fired and he wrote out a
memo while you're pulling it up i have
it here so i'll just read it
jeff sugger jeff zucker a world-class
sleazebag who has headed ratings and
and real news challenged cnn for too
long uh for far too long has been
terminated for numerous reasons or
predominantly because cnn has lost its
way with viewers and everybody else now
it's a chance to put fake news in the
backseat because there may not be
anything more important than
straightening out the horrendous
lame stream media in our country
and in this case of cnn throughout the
world jeff zucker is gone
congratulations to all okay
that's your uh that's your guy saying
that you were at his place yesterday
right i was at trump uh can i brought
you some gifts and i appreciate it if
kai's listening i would love him to to
bring in the gifts that i brought for
pat but by the way
i don't know if this is a
a left or right thing
because this is just a power thing
there's two things going on here cnn's
ratings are in the tank i'm sure you
want to transition to maybe the talker
story which is applicable here but this
is a powerful thing this happened to
roger ailes this happened to bill
o'reilly this happened to charlie rose
this happened to matt lauer this
happened to chris cuomo whether it's
harvey weinstein even this is a power
move you're you're if you're the head of
a network or the face of a network
you've got the power you've got the
money
everything that happened with roger
ailes is applicable here to jeff zucker
and where you know when you're the guy
in charge and you see a pretty little
marketing lady over there you're gonna
step into my office do a little twirl
let's see the outcome is that how it
goes
allegedly i don't know
so i i mean to me i'm sure that there's
more of the story i think to your point
with uh it being cuomo
there's probably going to be more more
to come out of it too like he's not
he's obviously pissed and taking the
ship with him or at least trying i i
would bet that you'll see more
more backlash and maybe even more people
either quitting or getting fired you
fire your best guy yeah and then you
trash him
no man you can't you can't do that well
do you remember when we talked about cnn
thinking about br they're bringing in
chris wallace yeah because they're
getting bought out by this guy john
malone and he he can't stand cnn he's a
serious person with serious goals who
has and he said quote he wants to bring
it back to actual journalism can you
show this picture by the way with tyler
simon discovery board member john malone
uh uh lost fox news before saying he
wants cnn to evolve back to actual
journalism and i don't want to say i
called this a couple months ago but
yeah it's because of this new owner he
he wants actual journalism he
understands that cnn is a joke and as
you guys say it's ratings now why
they're going with but ratings sucks so
their strategy is not working that's why
he wants to switch it and he's kicking
out jeff sucker why they went with that
for the excuse
to tell me you mean to tell me como
didn't fire zucker
here's what happened with cuomo cuomo
probably made a phone call and he said
listen
here's what you guys want to do to me
you want to ruin my reputation and hurt
my family
just know that's not the right move and
i don't appreciate that and then boom it
led to a conversation together with them
and obviously the rest is history i mean
because that article was from
mid-november
this is two hours ago from insider cnn
insider suspect chris cuomo flag jeff
zucker's workplace relationship has
revenge there you go and i don't even i
this is when this is when we just went
live on the podcast this is two hours
ago yeah so get out of here so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye